I am here with the acclaimed chef and
owner of the famed restaurant so Kara in
Pachuca meheeco he's also yeah took us
in the house which was in the Casa he's
also the star of Top Chef Mako please
welcome chef Aquila shovel
[Applause]
thank you I'd be ready to try the mix
you can't miss it I want to experience
the real Mexican cuisine and you are the
man to do it
that's what mine says we're gonna make a
margarita margarita
great all right did you like the chili
chili yeah perfect when I make a
margarita with chili
Sheila jalapeno okay this is for a real
man okay all right what do you think
you're talking to
I'm just asking just for someone back
here you're looking at to see these guys
do that with the happy okay brain right
here perfect so best the US has to offer
okay how that hurts okay okay got it
we need to put in the blender okay ice
ice I love of ice Oh
I'm not a very good precise person okay
put chili jalapeño how much chili do we
put in there depends if you are so man I
mean I really meant I really much that's
okay let me do lemon juice and he's been
no way cuz you make when you cooking it
ah ah that's it sugar sugar ass you guys
so kappa cyka cyka
so sequestered yeah that's it all right
um contra it's like all right orange a
little bit of yeah okay good tequila
tequila tequila tequila see hey okay
come on
my friend Lisa green low 20s Tammy
mother right over particular oh okay
okay I got it
yeah perfect I think I see no come on
come on
he's my he's my spring break oh okay no
blanket when did wait okay
houston we have a problem okay okay okay
I'm diggin for you yes yes under this I
like him on the rocks okay there you go
there you go it's all okay come here
come here
okay this is my this is my green boy I
do drunken goat say Khaleesi I'm getting
there all right okay yeah octopus
octopus in his own ink pulpo's including
tah-dah see so we need we need a poop
all right hey I see a lot of people they
ask me how to make to to to the coupons
gonna be tender
yes so you need to hit you need to party
hit it what do I hit with this if you're
gonna bot yeah and a hammer oh my god
okay you can you can we got you're my
daughter
wait I don't that's it oh my gosh what's
up oh okay put it to cook what to cook
we cook it now and we looking at are you
sure just yet yeah of course is dead
leave it from the 20 minutes 20 minutes
Oh steady steady okay right so we have
already done now now that Martha Stewart
cake we already did it
so that
yeah that's that's already cut all the
burpees olive oil olive oil
yes put in there okay okay perfect nice
so we need to put onions onions onions
chopped onions chopped onions tomatoes
tomatoes kitto mata ki tamaki Tom that's
right again he told me you got it okay I
got it
Chile Chile Chile more Chile
Oh God more cheerful okay alright the
octopus octopus already cook it don't
put them right now I know I'm not that
stupid
sure I'm stupid but not that's ok ok
then we put the octopus on pull you'll
be Nagar vinegar yeah white vinegar
vinegar yeah perfect and of course the
ink ink it has to cook in it - Hank yeah
the ink you put your ink here so that's
good I love your hair yeah look my hair
but you know what I like your mustache
does he not have the best house - come
on a mustache mustache
[Applause]
you know the problem every time now okay
now I'm getting in the telenovela now
now I get the woman here we go okay okay
me amigo my precious my precious
refreshed so okay that could be 20
minutes 20 minutes without the octuple
already cooked sister with the rice on
the side
yes okay very good with her off on the
side on the side okay try at least try
this right there octopus okay there's
gonna be good with a roast on the side
inside without black with pull up to
football Cosenza Pinta lovely you see
the put boys for tinder tinder okay
what's this they go out come only what
come on it
aw come on yeah but thrilled Mexican
guacamole okay so we need avocados more
aguacate do you know what doesn't mean
happy I woke up today they come from the
Nahuatl language and means this this MSE
chemical are great abakada right huge I
will cut this one are you saying your
testicles in Mexico we decide doctor we
have the Mexicans
that's why is why you sir does every so
because we're so much of yeah and it's
why you never see anyone wearing shorts
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in Mexico when just look at the two rows
we need a churro okay are you putting
the deep fry fry Wow make a huge to
Mexico we wait the totals with the hot
chocolate with the chocolate also put on
chili yeah can I ask you a question what
do you not put chilies on is there one
food in Mexico their medicines the
Minnesota baby gets a bottle of milk you
put chili
- Linda Cognito here's my ice cream oh
yeah sure come on Oh incredible two days
on the penicillin that's it so after
this fry you get an e please try the
tour of his lovely scrunchies sleep are
you covered with the sugar and cinnamon
booster this is perfect for the hangover
hangover you're gonna be like a champion
but the Toro
sometimes the Mexicans will call when
you make a alteration I'd join everyone
in
[Applause]
unless you're head of us that's it I'm
gonna show you this a little bit of time
left I'm gonna show you the real Mexican
purchased economy aircraft would you
ease in saco believe nobody it is
[ __ ] how dare you insult Taco Bell
yeah well example Jeff yeah
Jeff Ross he doesn't even listen to me
Jeff Ross Taco Bell they're a sponsor of
our show but this is Mexico I mean
everything I wish if you couldn't
wrangle Ohio thanks for the money
guess you suck
yeah but this shirt so you put a the top
coat would claim I know I guess now I
don't have a place to live and we have
no money anymore we'll make contact deep
fried actors you're going to get these
are the crunchy topping yes how is this
different than a Flautas
and this hundred this Turkish is topping
with the one with barbacoa lambreaux
McDowell's sure to say this is so good
it has been such an honor
this guy is a genius he's also very
funny and a true artist thank you so
much
[Applause]